conoce el primer invitado al día nos
vamos a hablar de la Segunda visita de
estado más Estados Unidos el presidente
francés Emmanuel macrón una oportunidad
para relanzar una amistad histórica
entre los dos países que también
comparten intereses Como por ejemplo el
apoyo esto durante la invasión rusa pero
también para tratar temas espinosos no
tan amables Como por ejemplo las
tensiones que desató la llamada crisis
de los submarinos y la ley para la
reducción de la inflación que Europa
señala como proteccionista nos acompaña
nuestro estudio Eugenio y Richard
analista experta en relaciones
internacionales docente investigadora en
la universidad de exterrado de Colombia
eugeni Gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo América de France 24 buena
mañana de miércoles Buenos días cómo
llega digamos el presidente Emmanuel
macron en esta oportunidad en esta
Segunda visita de estado a Estados
Unidos vamos a comparar también un poco
no como fue Esta visita Hace cuatro años
cuando estaba el presidente Donald Trump
en la casa blanca y ahora con un calma
de administración o cambio también de
partido los demócratas en el poder con
Joe biden claro entonces hace cuatro
años no olvidamos que Manuel Magnum
había llegado con la esperanza de hacer
evolucionar el 12 iraní sobre los
nuclear y fue un fracaso entonces este
año pues es una visita de estado es una
visita sumamente protocolar pero
Emmanuel ha dicho que no quería quedarse
en lo protocolar y que quería lograr
avances sobre dos principales temas el
primero que es Ucrania y quien dice
Ucrania Pues dice Rusia necesariamente y
el segundo es esta ley entonces que está
percibida como proteccionista por parte
de los europeos que es la ley ira
inflation and reducción acta y Emmanuel
Pues sabe bien que si esta ley que
perjudica entonces las empresas
extranjeras de penetrar el mercado
estadounidense en el tema de energías
renovables no la va a poder tumbar sin
embargo le gustaría entonces lograr
algunas exoneraciones sobre ciertos para
cier cierto sectores para facilitar
digamos la penetración de Este mercado
norteamericano hablemos de estos temas a
Punto por punto eugenei y comenzamos
hablando de esta guerra en Ucrania el
apoyo fundamental que ha tenido Estados
Unidos y también Europa no como bloque
como conjunto Para apoyar a los
ucranianos a defenderse de los rusos
claro Entonces desde el principio pues
la Unión Europea Emanuel Majo en
personas se ha comprometido a respaldar
Kids sin embargo eso le está costando
bastante la Unión Europea entonces
Estados Unidos está beneficiando de de
esta posición porque le está vendiendo
su gas a la Unión Europea caro pero
también le está vendiendo armas
porque los europeos han entregado
muchísimas armas a Ucrania entonces
mientras Estados Unidos está
beneficiando de esta guerra pues la
Unión Europea está pagando un precio muy
alto Entonces el argumento de Manuel es
que no puede asegurar una posición
unificada de la Unión Europea frente
este dossier ruso si Estados Unidos por
su lado no está haciendo Entonces un
paso hacia la Unión Europea y permite
entonces a la Unión Europea entrar en el
mercado norteamericano en contra de esta
ley que recién fue aprobada Entonces los
dos temas están ligados y digamos que
aquí va a haber un tigre y afloje
seguramente entre los dos mandatos para
saber a qué compromiso pueden llegar el
Johnny también como lo estábamos
diciendo en nuestra introducción van a
hablar de temas no tan amigables no
obviamente lo que pasó con esta Alianza
aucus cuando Australia decidió romper
este multimillonario contrato que tenía
con los franceses para usar tecnología
de punta para los submarinos y decidió
Entonces ahora hacer esta Alianza con
Estados Unidos O para cambiar de Francia
a Estados Unidos Entonces qué va a pasar
con todo esto cómo pueden quedar
entonces las relaciones atrás en lo que
pudieran compensar los mandatarios sobre
este tema claro ha sido un duro golpe
este este tema de los submarino Ema se
había declarado entonces muy
decepcionado por este este asunto
Entonces ahora intentamos pasar la
página no olvidamos que entonces Francia
es el primer país invitado para una
visita de estado significa que Estados
Unidos está ratificando que Francia es
un Aliado de peso es el primer
interlocutor de Estados Unidos en la
región Y entonces le está haciendo los
honores a Francia para intentar de
concretizar nuevos acuerdos en temas
empresariales pero no solamente no
olvidemos que Manuel majón no viaja solo
viaja con toda la élite económica
empresarial pero también científica
cultural entonces pensamos que Estados
Unidos ahí se va a mostrar bastante
abierto a la firma de nuevos compromisos
En todos estos temas para pasar un
poquito la página de esta crisis de los
submarinos también de otra parte macron
espera tratar con el presidente Joe vaya
en el impacto esta llamada ley para la
reducción de la inflación aprobada
recientemente en Estados Unidos no y que
la Unión Europea ha tildado de
proteccionista porque la Unión Europea
ha tildado esta ley de proteccionista
además el impacto que tiene en las
empresas europeas es una ley
proteccionista porque esta ley indica
que las empresas extranjeras tendrán más
dificultades de vender sus productos en
el campo de las energías renovables en
Estados Unidos y que bajo el lema de
América First Entonces se dará la
prioridad a las empresas norteamericanas
sobre estos temas estamos hablando
entonces de energías renovable estamos
hablando de carros eléctricos estamos
hablando de batería todo un sector que
Francia ha desarrollado mucho y que
además es una bandera de gobierno del
presidente macrón Entonces sí no
solamente Francia la Unión Europea
piensa que esta ley puede perjudicar sus
exportaciones en estos temas y en este
caso pues Emmanuel Juan tiene este
deber de poder hacer avanzar sobre este
12 recordamos que la cámara de
representantes pasó a ser republicana
Hace algunos días Entonces Emmanuel que
no la podrá tumbar pero de pronto puede
tener alguna exageraciones Sí sí las
puede tener a ese punto Quería llegar si
puede llegar a tener algunas excepciones
conversando con el presidente Joey en
evidentemente es un Pues un proceso
político no solamente lo que diga el
presidente yo bailén pero pudieran
llegar a un acuerdo en ciertos puntos o
la verdad es que no bueno Joe vaina no
tiene ya tantos libertad como tenía
antes recordamos que tiene que componer
con el congreso pero esta del viaje
acompañando de Manuel Magno el el
presidente de total Energy que es la
gran petrolera francesa y entonces pues
imaginamos que si él está del viaje es
porque Sí seguramente vamos a poder
tener una conversación quería en este
sentido
también Esta visita de estado se acaba
el día viernes que pudiéramos concluir
lo más importante de de
visita el presidente matrona a Estados
Unidos bueno va a quedar el lado
simbólico protocolar Francia como gran
Aliado de Estados Unidos la primera
fuerza política invitada en el país
Los acuerdos veremos que tantos son los
más importantes Entonces es que Manuel
Magnum pueda negociar frente a Estados
Unidos diciendo Bueno si ustedes nos
ayudan de pronto sobre esta ley ira
nosotros podemos ayudar a que la Unión
Europea siga teniendo una posición
unificada frente al doce de Rusia pero
también frente a China no olvidemos que
Estados Unidos tiene a China como un
gran competidor y Manuel Mackenzie Pues
denos algo porque de pronto si nos da
nada pues tampoco podemos asegurar que
le Seguiremos apoyando frente a Rusia y
frente a China claro ahí pues las
jugadas políticas que tendrían que hacer
eugeni Gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros esta mañana de miércoles en
directo América de France 24